pretty good guests on the show okay
we've had well we had Jordan Peele
Academy Award winning now or he's
nominated yeah we got we had stone
Street on but this one's a really good
one guys we hooked up a good one he has
a Netflix special out what's it called
disgraceful I said not to talk sorry
time to juice your name and that was a
test
alright okay it's called disgraceful
yeah and Tom Segura everybody clap your
hands Tom Segura thank you thanks for
having me but thinking oh my God why did
you want to do this y'all know what it
is cuz I just wanted to hang out with
you Bob oh you are one of the nicest
guys I've ever [ __ ] met I never you
remind me of Eric Griffin in the sense
that like there's no showbiz weirdness
it's an [ __ ] yeah I know but he's he
would have been an [ __ ] if he was a
coal miner oh I mean I love Eric nothing
nice guy already like this Eric Griffin
would have been an [ __ ] wherever he
is that's who he is
right anyway so that's what I'm saying
yeah that his ass wholeness is just who
he is
right yeah he's a nice guy that's just
who he is Tom Segura okay and before we
get into anything I'm gonna just tell
the people how I met him um wilee met
you and this is how I truly I know when
I actually actually met you the very
first time okay well what's a that first
time the very first time I met you would
have been like around 2004 or 5
something like that yeah on the streets
of Melrose and it was after a show at
The Improv and I saw you you're at a car
like a really tall woman she blonde yeah
no Sara those I was dating Sarah it's
like 6 feet tall yeah yeah yeah and then
I saw you and I was like oh [ __ ] Bobby
Lee : I knew you from TV and I said
something to you
and then I like kind of like jokingly
soft pitched you a sketch yeah yeah
where yeah yeah yeah and then you
improvised with me and then you jumped
on my back like I gave you a piggyback
ride are you I literally jumped on your
back I'm done my back oh [ __ ] I was like
I'm probably on the show this week and
now okay so I hadn't seen you between
the story that I have yeah and that we
there was really no I mean a couple
times we like I would say hi yeah but I
didn't really know you know you and then
I would say something you'd be like
that's racist dude right right yeah so I
get booked on the oddball Comedy
Festival yeah and I find out that it's
summer of 2016
yes this beautiful summer of 2016 I
remember it like it was yes a couple
years ago yes and I can't I couldn't
believe they asked me to do it but um so
we go I go to the airport and it's
Sebastian Maniscalco was that the
airport
tom was there I think Dane Cook was
there and you know we were supposed to
get our own tickets so my manager Abbey
juju
she's Jewish she wants to save money so
she always gives me coach
oh honey it's not a big test there's no
difference right yeah yeah so these guys
get first class yeah so I'm talking to
them in the you know you know okay yeah
weird giggling their first class and
they all leave I'm like now I blush and
I'm going right and you know me said let
me say something walking by I don't know
how Christ felt when he was like holding
the thing and yeah throwing rocks but it
felt you know similar yeah I would
assume the only thing I regretted in
that moment yeah was that I wasn't all
ready better friends with you because
then I would have enjoyed it you know I
feel sorry for him at that no I cause
with a comic you already like they let
you know what kind of person they are so
there's some comics who would have given
off the vibe of like don't make this a
thing yeah
and you kind of like if you can pick up
on people's yeah you know body language
and stuff you're like alright you'd be
like but he was playing into like he was
talking about it like I'm so embarrassed
go back there yeah yeah yeah I mean
that's what it was yeah they were like
booing did you boo I think told the
flight attendant to bring you stuff yeah
I could give this point yeah well no you
came back and threw a pillow army he
took a first-class pillow and it was a
use that you know mean and it was just
so embarrassing but then that's when I
knew that he was playful but here's when
I knew that I really liked him and that
he was a good guy is is that apparently
we were supposed to arrange our own
rides from the airport we were in Austin
yeah to the hotel right and everyone got
off the plane first glad you know when
your friends are in first class and
you're in coach you would think that
they would wait for you
to deplane doesn't Ally on the flight -
yeah right no one did
straight into their limo they went right
under their limos that they their people
set up I don't have a limo enough I
don't know how many I don't even know
where I'm staying
alright so I'm like walking I don't see
anybody and I walk outside and I see Tom
standing there with his limo driver and
he says I just assumed that you don't
have a ride and I go correct great I'll
give you a ride to their hotel whoo [ __ ]
I don't know I'm about to cry who the
[ __ ] does that
I can't no no bigoted who does that I
mean not only we're not war buddies
we weren't Nam together yeah I wish it
was you know but um I don't know him
that much I don't know him he does that
that's [ __ ] dope for all like I I
would probably hurt somebody for you
thanks buddy yeah you're welcome that
wonderful guy you know what I thought I
remembered don't know if I'm wrong about
the yeah I did make the assumption you
didn't have the car and I waited yeah
didn't you come down and go like oh like
where's my car oh yeah yeah yeah yeah
you're like is my guy here you don't
have a guy I mean a normal committee
would have fired it's [ __ ] people
from no dude they just you know it's
know they they they hung me out to dry
then we had a good talk on the way that
we did
[Music]
[Music]